Lucy are we boring no I'm not you might
be you know we need to do hmm
let's get out of here and let's go on a
group vacation yes
get crazy spice things up yes yes we
could run like one of those big fancy
houses remember last time we did that in
Santa Barbara
Todd sheep down on everything oh no how
is he even an adult so it's only 250
each yeah it's not bad right I'll give
you 75 and then I'm gonna take a little
bottle wine hackling with me what are
you doing what it's free isn't it we
grab some groceries from the store so
you just throw sketch whenever no thanks
got my own you're gonna bacon the whole
trip Todd we're going wine tasting you
should probably put some pants on where
does it cost why are we friends of him
sweetmeat slavery Oh what about skiing
remember the last time we went up north
Milo and his baby bladder
he's like a chihuahua oh you know what
though Vegas isn't that far except I'd
have to lecture Ben who is even gambling
or something oh no no it's a packin
thing what do you mean every time we
stay in a hotel he brings our entire
house oh hey what's going on we're going
to Vegas for a night you know that most
hotels provide bedding right yeah it's
Vegas though yeah but good call on a
skateboard and the teddy bear could you
grab this so I can get my arm out yeah
this is my college backpack that is
insane I love my husband but maybe it
should just be you and me as long as we
can have separate rooms which what he'll
make sure happens because this man that
the medical condition
you see dead people does it cheap I knew
it
calm down she's having a night tear you
sound like a monkey being murdered in
the woods
well how about the time we put you in
charge of the room reservation and the
last time we went to Vegas I remember a
fun night I'm very overrated [ __ ] the
hotel for the wrong night we can't get
it till tomorrow you know what things
don't close in Vegas they say motel oh
yeah not that big of a deal maybe we
should just stay here and cook you keep
your shoes in your stone get any closets
you know look at tiny this thing is we
could make shoestring right no no stop
it I go I can't handie shoes are made
for fake what is wrong with you today